[Musique]
le préfet de martinique dans son caddie
ce matin pour tenter peut-être de
rassurer la population bonjour franck
robine mangeurs dangereuse auditeurs
lors d'opérations de contrôle la chaîne
cher et au lamentin avant-hier vous avez
reconnu une explosion de la circulation
des armes dans notre île une explosion
de cette circulation d'armes à rix ben
il faut reconnaître qu'il faut désigner
les choses telles qu'elles sont et à
situation exceptionnelle réponse
exceptionnelle donc j'ai demandé à
l'ensemble des pauvres forces de police
de gendarmerie des douanes de se
mobiliser d'être très présente sur le
terrain pour répondre à cette situation
bien évidemment on y reviendra mais
lorsque vous parlez de l'explosion de
circulation des armes
ça veut dire que vous pouvez quantifier
ce phénomène vous avez des données
chiffrées alors on a bien sûr avant tout
ce que nous disent les policiers de ce
qu'ils observent sur leur qu'est ce qui
vous laisse des policiers parce que
lorsqu'on leur pose la question ne
disent pas combien d'armes ont été
saisies
les policiers nous disent que il est
très régulier c'est à dire plusieurs
fois par semaine vous arrêter des gens
qui détiennent des armes
ça a été le cas c'est aussi parce que
les policiers occupent le terrain parce
qu'ils sont très présents que nous
pouvons faire c'est saisie et moi je
voudrais vraiment les féliciter parce
que les affaires de ces derniers jours
par exemple celle de samedi soir où ils
ont arrêté quatre personnes qui
détenaient de glock
c'est à dire des pistolets automatiques
et une autre arme de poing nous montrent
qu'on occupe le terrain et c'est
essentiel on parle d'armes réelles
d'armes factices parce qu'il ya aussi
des vidéos qui ont circulé au cours du
week-end dernier on voit par exemple
cette femme dans les rues du lamentin
brandissant une arme effectivement un
passant il ya aussi ces collégiens
devant la mairie de fort-de-france avec
désormais voilà toujours des armes
factices des armes réelles
comment comment peut-on faire le
distinguo justement ces vidéos elles
sont très choquantes
il s'avère que nous avons immédiatement
identifié ces collégiens que les
contacts ont été pris avec les parents
par la police nationale et elles sont
choquantes et cela me conduit dès
aujourd'hui dès ce matin à prendre un
arrêté pour interdire
porter ses armes sur la voie publique
c'est un factice de les exhiber sur la
voie publique ça concernera bien sûr les
mineurs mais cette concernera tous les
martiniquais et tous les martiniquais ce
je crois qu'il faut vraiment qu'il y ait
une prise de conscience comment ne
peut-on pas être choqué de constater que
ces collégiens exhibe des armes
j'ai envie de vous dire que font les
parents et donc la ficelle est là pour
réagir
elle est là pour agir pour occuper le
terrain mais je crois aussi qu'il faut
une prise de conscience des institutions
des associations et des parents pour
remédier à ce phénomène mais monsieur
robin savait qu'on vend des pistolets
pour les jeux vidéo vous savez qu'on
gens en vendée des pistolets des armes à
feu factice dans les bazars chinois ça
se retrouve sur internet parce que voilà
c'est une société qu'il veut c'est
également la société de commerce et donc
c'est la société du commerce on concilie
liberté du commerce et de l'industrie et
au comportement que je qualifie encore
une fois de choquant c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous pouvez acheter une
arme si vous êtes amateurs chacun on a
le droit de le faire pour les armes
factices mais vous ne pourrez plus les
exhibé en public
et puis j'ajoute que c'est quand même
très dangereux comment voulez vous qu'un
policier soit capable de reconnaître une
arme factice d'une arme réelle
donc c'est vraiment très dangereux alors
osez parler des contrôles sur le terrain
c'était le cas avant-hier à schoelcher
et au lamentin avec des applications sur
mobile ces contrôles de ces varié au
bout de dix minutes puisque tout le
monde est au courant comment faire pour
contrôler sur le terrain avec de tel
avec la technologie depuis le 21 mai
avec ce qui s'est passé à volga j'ai
demandé aux forces de police de
gendarmerie d'être très présente sur le
terrain
elles ont fait quasiment une opération
par nuit il y en a certaines qu'on
médiatise
celle que nous avons médiatisé
avant-hier pour montrer qu'on occupe le
terrain effectivement a fait l'objet de
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est pas important l'important c'est
que ont dissuadé dissuade contre aux
voyous qu'on ne les laissera pas opérer
sur la voie publique
c'est le sens de ces opérations est ce
que vous voudrez bien entendre également
que lorsque vous venez ce genre
d'opération ça fait un peu sourire
quelque part parce que vous allez dans
n'importe quelle commune aux abords de
n'importe quels établissements scolaires
collèges lycées dans n'importe quel bar
et bien les riverains pourront vous dire
mais c'est là que se vend la drogue
c'est de là que si aucune voix si même
le chemin pourquoi ne pas intervenir là
directement alors vous pointez le second
point d'action que nous avons en commun
avec le procureur de la république qui
est celui de l'anc est la réponse aux
armes et aux trafics
elle est double elle est une occupation
du terrain par les forces de police et
de gendarmerie je n'y reviens pas et
puis il ya les enquêtes judiciaires et
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers dernières semaines nous
mobilisons de façon exceptionnelle les
forces de police judiciaire le directeur
régional de la police judiciaire de
guadeloupe est venu travailler avec nous
avec le procureur de la république et
moi même je suis allé à paris voir le
directeur de cabinet du ministre de
l'intérieur
j'ai vu également le directeur général
de la police nationale donc ça c'est le
volet enquête il ya tous les tous les
moyens tous les le paquet comme on dit
sont mis pour retrouver les auteurs et
je vais vous dire ma conviction ils le
seront assez rapidement parlons de
l'insécurité mais une autre forme de
sécurité franck robine ces familles du
littoral lucéens des familles contre est
de voir des personnes désormais à
quelques centimètres de chez elle sans
aucune intimité
souvent pris à partie quelle solution
pour elle victime de l'avancée de la mer
on se souvient qu'il ya quelques jours
avec des associations ont voulu faire le
ménage sur le littoral sous la fameuse
zone des 50 pas géométriques
alors je vais vous dire une chose
d'abord je renouvelle vraiment ma plus
ferme condamnation des exactions et des
violences qui ont été commises et il y
aura des suites judiciaires
il y aura des suites judiciaires les
dossiers sont constitués
ça c'est le premier point est maintenant
le deuxième point c'est que je pense que
toutes les conditions de traitement
sereine de ce dossier sont réunis
j'avais pris des engagements c'est de
présenter en quinze jours un projet de
cheminement le long du littoral
je rappelle que la loi il s'applique
pour tous et la loi elle est très claire
elle dit que le cheminement le long du
littoral doit être assurée j'ai donc
dans les quinze jours proposé ce
cheminement au maire de sainte-luce que
je tiens à remercier pour son appui son
investissement dans ce dossier aux
propriétaires aux associations
ce projet vous le savez il est public il
doit maintenant être conforté c'est à
dire que nous avons besoin compte tenu
de l'érosion des côtes de relever à
nouveau les plats ou et les points ou
sohu et le domaine public maritime
ce sera fait à la fin du mois de juin et
tout le monde pourra instaurer et vivre
sereinement dans le respect de quelques
extraits doit à quelques hectomètres de
chez nous de la tour 2009 robin il y à
ses habitants du côté de la pointe la
vierge qui sont également les pieds dans
l'eau vous allez paix et établir un
nouveau tracé pour ces personnes
du côté de certains quartiers disons
chic relevé huppé du françois du
rossberg également des maisons qui sont
quasiment dans l'eau vous allez
intervenir mais également celles hors la
loi littoral elle est très claire elle
établit le leap cheminement le long du
littoral
il ya 440 kilomètres de côtes en
martinique c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai saisi les maires vous le savez je
leur ai demandé pour la fin du mois de
mai de m'indiquer là où il y a des
problèmes je note ce que vous me dites
donc je suppose que les maires en
question des communes concernées vont
m'écrire pour me permette de new york
ces sujets là et puis par ailleurs le
seul robin et puis la décision de payer
l etat c
bien fait je dois le dire puisque elle a
prévu beaucoup de souplesse d'action
elle a prévu aussi de reconnaître les
droits historiques des propriétaires
lorsqu'il y en a il faut le dire il y a
des cassettes le sac qui ont été
reconnus par exemple si avant 2010 qui
la date d'entrée en vigueur de la loi
j'ai parfois entendu 1986 je tiens à le
dire le décret d'application il est de
2010 si vous aviez une propriété
légalement établie cerné par exemple de
murs en dur et bien dans ces cas là la
loi prévue de contourner donc cette loi
encore une fois et je pense que les
associations de défense de la social de
l'environnement l'ont reconnu cette loi
elle est là pour s'appliquer
on peut le faire intelligemment en fait
en travaillant c'est donc un doute que
nous arrivons sur son lay reliant comme
ailleurs à établir ce libre je savais ce
que disent et associations qu'ils ou
elles vous contraignent à faire le job
le job de l'état
si je condamne vraiment avec la plus
ferme énergie les violences qui ont été
commises
je pense que l'association assauts pas
marre que vous citez a compris qu'on
pouvait être dans le dialogue et
travailler intelligemment
je les ai reçus vous le savez pendant
plus de deux heures et demie
immédiatement après les faits je crois
qu'elles ont compris que j'étais
fermement décidé à faire appliquer la
loi
elles me font confiance et je pense que
les propriétaires peuvent me faire
confiance aussi pour trouver les voies
des clients n'y aura pas deux poids deux
mesures la loi s'appliquera en
martinique
monsieur le temps ça vous étonne non non
non moi je vous pose des questions pour
nathan vos réponses et puis surtout on
verra ce que ça donnera sur le terrain
de la réalité des choses merci d'avoir
été se bat avec nos familles dit elle on
aurait pu parler du pack ultra marins
d'investissement dans les compétences
malheureusement ne sont pris par le
temps on y reviendra
puisque ce pacte sera signé bientôt avec
ça il s'agit de formations pour retenir
les jeunes martinique c'est un
investissement exceptionnel qui pour
l'état représentent 69 millions d'euros
pour la formation notamment des
demandeurs n'avaient seconde un peu plus
haut concernant ce pacte oui bah c'est
un engagement du président
public il avait 10 15 milliards sur son
mandat pour la formation professionnelle
ça représente 700 millions d'euros pour
les outre-mer et 70 millions pour pour
l'état avec ça on peut financer vraiment
les formations les plus adaptés pour
permettre aux gens d'accéder au travail
parce qu'il ya aussi du travail la
situation est difficile en martinique
mais il ya des gisements d'emplois il ça
permettrait surtout de fixer les
martiniquais ne fixer d'autres
populations auxquelles rester ici à fort
de france et partout en martinique merci
franck robine préfet de martinique
d'avoir été se battait dans son caddie
merci
[Musique]